Please ignore the fact that I doxed the the minor I was in my
chat to try to help Kiwi Farms find her. Please ignore that part.
There's just no way. There's no possible way that people could
be this stupid. Dude, >> I I did think it was interesting
some of the responses I've been getting to like tweets about
food shops and it's like all broken English Twitter accounts
with like 11 followers talking about how lively isn't a problem.
>> Does this guy have a caretaker? How in the world could
you possibly think the shady in the background has to do with
Dubby's work? That's crazy. God. >> Um, I'm going to go
to sleep cuz I've got a headache. >> Go. Be careful.
>> Of course, Destiny did not go to sleep. He came immediately
to my stream, started talking my stream, and then 3 hours later
came back into my chat again to try to talk again.
That was just a joke. Okay, I've got a screen recording here
of some DMs. I'm just going to do this real quick. Okay, we'll
throw this in. Maybe we'll cover it later if more people come
on. But I haven't looked at this yet. And this is um
Wick and Doobie apparently talking about
some of the stuff to do with Destiny. You know, menacing Doobie
the other night. I was told this is a screen recording of those
Discord logs. All right. from this morning.
>> Okay. Chorus is bad. IMO, want to come on my show about
it next week? Wait, I assume you mean the David Pacman thing.
Uh, what's the chorus thing? So,
Wick, after not criticizing Destiny at all for that. Not, By
the way, um, the end of that stream. Hold on, let me pull it
up again. Let me pull up that time stamp. Somebody had that time
stamp for me. I should go pull that time stamp up because the
end of that stream
was a little goofy. Okay, who sent it to me? What was the stream
called? I think if I think if I go find it on his channel, I'll
just show you guys what we're talking about because I I should
reintroduce it. I don't know if all of you were around late last
night when we looked at it. Okay, but let me look at the time
stamp here. 9050.
>> Pretty brutal.
>> So, for having me, >> of course. And uh this as
Destiny's leaving, he brings up the wick thing. >> I hope
you feel better and have a good day. Bye-bye. >> Thanks.
Oh, also major shout out. I saw that you um hosted a debate where
um it was really crazy. I think Doobie was getting smashed by
Peach and Zip Zip. Did you see that? Where he got
>> Yeah. It was probably one of the worst performers I've
ever seen of any person in my entire life. I actually I'm not
sure. Do you know if Dy's like special
>> Did that Did that happen? Cuz I could have sworn like
it was funny. Maybe I didn't watch far enough through. But it
was like Zip Zip going like, "You said I jerked off on Pixie's
door handle of her car." Am I muted? This is not going through
me. Nope, not muted. Uh, okay. Right. Like the Zip Zip saying
that and Dub is like, "It's a joke, but you are a weirdo." And
now given how weird you are and given this weird conversation
we're having now, uh, I do think you jerked off on her door handle.
Right.
I I didn't think Duby I didn't think Duby was like didn't look
like he was getting like owned or anything. >> I don't
know. Or >> if you want to debate Doobie, I can set it
up.
>> Uh no, cuz I know that he's really upset with you for
platforming me and he thinks that that's like a really bad thing
and he tries to do a whole bunch of weird creepy like, you know,
stuff in the background to imp
you ask about that. Can you ask what weird creepy things in the
background
What's weird creepy stuff in the background? Can anyone tell
me? He just goes like weird creepy stuff in the background. He
does like his grabbler hands. Just weird creepy weird stuff.
Like the only person we know who does weird creepy weird stuff
in DMs. Is this like what? How does he accuse Doobie? By the
way, I think Dubby's weird stuff apparently is just going to
public Discords and being like, I think this Destiny guy's a
weirdo. Or possibly posting in Pisco's public YouTube chat. These
are the weird things he does. the creepy weird things he does
in the >> But you know what, Wick? Good on you for standing
on principal. I think you're a good guy. I congratulate you for
that. Even when there are creepy weirdo in the background who
own insurance companies and that do kind of weird stuff to try
to pressure people to do stuff like I think it's really >> Okay,
so this is a thing that Destiny does a lot. This is a pattern
he actually has. Hold on. >> I'm going to ruin your pattern.
>> you weren't around in the beginning of Twitch poll,
but maybe some of your viewers were. There's something about
like uh movers and shakers in Twitch poll. So I think that's
what he's referring to. There was like Jubie, someone called
Danabo, someone called Samantha Banana. Like a bunch of people
were called like doing stuff in the background like control people.
I think that's what he's referring to. >> Is that what
Are you sure that's what he's referring to?
that goes back like a long time ago. I >> like years like
>> so I'm sort of aware of that because of the weird >> I
that that got caught up in some Chud drama that I got shown a
while back right with Dylan Burns and stuff. Dylan Burns talking
about it.
>> And and I think Danabo either Danabo or somebody else
joked about how Chud logic can only afford to eat pot noodle.
Okay. And Chud has like never let that go that this guy like
joked about how Chud was not making any money. I bring it up
because what he refers to here, I think you would be have to
you would have to dig in that time around that time when there
was like the movers and shakers thing to catch Danabo, not Danbo,
but um Doobie talking about that he possibly was in insurance.
So, I think if he's pulling information from back then, he might
be calling him like a creeper in the background because of the
same uh narratives that were being spun back then. I think somebody
told me that he mentioned insurance or something on the Prime
Kai panel, but I I have not looked into it at all. I've not seen
it. Either
>> uh Okay. Okay. Thanks. Uh either way, I believe that
um dropping like just what Duby does for a job. This is like
a classic thing Destiny does. It's it the pattern is like he'll
just drop like little things he knows to try to menace you away
from like talking about him, being around him. He just does it
all the time, right? like he'll try to drop these little things
to menace you away and it's just it's an indication that like
he he sees you he sees that you are like talking [__]
about him and he's not going to let it go. Right.
That's that's what I see here is he's he's like oh like some
people who run insurance companies it's like I know stuff about
you. I know more about you. I'll talk more about you if you keep
talking about me. Yeah, that's that's basically exactly what
it is. And it's not hard to see it, right? It's not hard to see
that that's what he's doing here in my opinion. Is this like
a straightup dox threat? I don't know. But given that Destiny
has the capacity to dox people who he says run narratives in
the background on him and right that he's basically said it's
open season on those people, I do think it gets really concerning
really quickly when he's basically justified doing this to other
people before and he's menacing uh Duby in that exact direction
like with that ex basically a very very similar allegation. I
think you're a good guy. I congratulate you for that. Even when
there are creepy weirdo in the background who own insurance companies
and that do kind of weird stuff to try to pressure people to
do stuff like I think it's really weird and creepy. So good for
you, Wick. Okay. I love you. >> Um I'm going to go to sleep
cuz I've got a headache. >> Go sleep. >> Of course,
Destiny did not go to sleep. He came immediately to my stream,
started talking my stream, and then 3 hours later came back into
my chat again to try to talk [__] again. Uh, the
best was at like I believe somewhere around 3:00 a.m. Was it
around 3:00 a.m. Miami time? It was like 2:00 a.m. 3:00 a.m.
Miami time. He came in here and was like, "I heard JTock and
Cherry were fighting cuz they didn't stream like two days ago
when like that morning I posted about how we went to weapons.
We went to like the movies on like a day."
It's like he just he just straight up doesn't understand normal
human things that happen.
I Dude, that's just that's rough for me. Okay. that he had to
come in here and be like, "I you guys didn't stream, so you guys
were fighting." I was like, "No, we went to the movies. Actually,
hung out. Some good stuff."
>> I think he should actually talk with Doobie.
Uh, if he's going to call him out, he should talk. >> Who's
Who's Blood talking to right now? Who's Who's Blood talking to?
He gone, bro. He gone.
Yeah. If you're going to say, "Dooby's doing weird, you should
show me what he's doing. You should say what he's doing. You
shouldn't just say things and then leave. It was very >> Talk
with Doobie. I think if I think that needs to happen now. What
do you guys think? Like if he mentions him. >> Okay, so
after this happened this morning, Wick says, "Oh, if you're upset
about the chorus thing, why don't you hop on stream and talk
about it?" Right. We need two anti- chorus folks for a show next
week. Oh boy. Is Doobie anti- Daily Wire? I don't know why you'd
be anti- one party having a media space and not another if you're
both. It's like, well, okay, I disagree, but at least have you're
principled. This person is not intelligent. That's rough. That's
rough. Let's see. I'm I'm looking for Dubbiey's response here.
Where's Doobie? Come back and say something. Doobie. Doobie.
Doobie. Doobie. Where's Doobie? They're talking through chorus
stuff. They're talking through chorus stuff. I'm assuming Doobie
comes back and says something here. I do appreciate that it's
a scroll of the whole chat, so you can see all of their opinions
on the chorus stuff, too. But I'm just waiting for the Duby to
come back here. Say something. Get this stirred again. Oh, hold
on. We missed something here. Atwick, if Parallax or Jeb Tan
or Joe or even Buckaroo had ended a stream with you by casually
softboxing a community member, would they still be here? Oh,
so a lot of his community I've heard this. A lot of his community
is actually quite upset that Destiny goes in, right? Destiny
goes in and says these things. Oh, hold on. I missed it. A green
name. Was there another one? Hold on. Somebody got a couple messages.
I blame your face.
Are you sure I missed Dub responding? Pass it up. You missed
it. Come on, man. Really? Oh, I did miss it. Jesus. It's right
there. Well, I need to focus on the icon. Here we go. Uh, I might
be able to do it, but I'm not sure to be honest. It's hard for
me to plan out that far ahead these days with the baby. Oh. Uh,
he didn't really say much. That makes sense. Next week makes
sense. And then we go down and we get to the the next one down
here, which is the girl asking that woman from the stream asking,
"Hey, would this be okay? We are right here." So, if these people
came on to like kind of menace this guy. Now, I will say I don't
know if I would call it soft doxing. It's menacing, right? That's
what it is. It's just a It's menacing him pretty openly. I also
like his failed attempts to be gigachad and also signal for a
truce with H3. We got to beat fascism fascism. I'm so above this
all, but I'll go on if you want to want me to. Dude, it's um
it's so funny that he does that. It's like I'm So, guys, I've
just been trying to like focus on politics. Please ignore the
fact that I doxed the the minor I was in my chat to try to help
Kiwi Farms find her. Please ignore that part. But other than
that, guys, I've totally been on board. Please ignore me doxing
all these other people, trying to dox all these other people.
But other than that, like, please understand that I've just been
focused on I've just been Please ignore me harassing Pixie and
all of my victims, okay? But other than those like three things
that are clearly nothing to do with fighting fascism, guys, I've
been focused on politics. We've been zeroed in on politics, okay?
We've been zeroed in. Let's see if Wick responds to this. What's
a soft dox? Asks Wick. For sake, do we have to bring up Destiny
every day? Uh, I mean, Destiny was just in your community last
night. Was just like on your stream last night. I I feel like
you probably talked about the content. I I know. I'm happy if
my community is talking about my content the next day. Maybe
maybe it's not something like that for Wick. Hey, you just had
Desion. That was your only content last night and then your community
is asking questions about that content. Seems like it. What?
Yeah, seems like you would want that. I don't know. Uh, so what's
mentioning the job/lo of a member? Did he actually mention a
job or did he say he knows the job? I was told the latter yesterday.
If that job wasn't something the individual has had talked about
a lot about a lot, maybe. But everyone knows Dubbie works insurance
cuz he talks about it publicly. To me, it feel to me it feels
more like the act and not the info is more important. Yep. If
that job wasn't some Oh, sorry. Sorry. We're here. I just don't
think that's a soft dox like Destiny. dead streamer who streams
from Florida is not a dox soft softer or otherwise. Uh I would
say when it's an anonymous person it's a little different when
you're alleging that he's conspiring in the background doing
weird [__] in the background right the same thing
you've doxed other people for I think it takes on a different
tone but maybe Wick disagrees that's not to say I agree with
the soft dox term either but no but I think the people sharing
the court docs showing the jurisdiction he's in are doxing and
and am also not okay with that. I mean that's a little different
with the whole public filing thing in my opinion. Isn't he public
about that too though? I honestly don't know why those are publicly
available. It doesn't make it not doxing.
Not like his address or anything. Oh my god, this is scrolling
very fast. It's one thing for the person to post it, another
for everyone else, especially before the person. Uh, intent.
If his info is being shared as a way of encouraging him getting
doxed, then that should be the difference. So, what was Destiny's
intent? I don't know. I was hoping you clarify. I can't know
his mind. I mean, Wick said he would go to the court, didn't
he? Wick said he would go to the courthouse. Yeah, which is just
bizarre considering he's apparently friends with both Pixie and
Destiny. Is he going to go watch Pixie cry about about this stuff?
I I can't imagine that being great. It'd be real hard to be like,
"What's up, Destiny? How's it going?" and then try to be a shoulder
to cry on for Pixie, too. Like, that would just be awkward, I
would think.
Thought you referring to the stream.
I got to turn this down a little bit. It's scrolling a little
too fast. We still have to go down. Hold on. Was Doobie's work
brought up as a veiled threat. Thought so, but oh [__]
we went I went way far back here. We're down to here. Just casually
DM him real quick. If he said it in a way to imply threat, then
any justification is cope. Implied threat should be a dealbreaker.
It did not come off as a threat to me, implied or otherwise.
Wait, what was the purpose then? Hold on, Wick TV. What was the
purpose of it?
Like, do we just have to go Let's just go back to it again. I
hate I hate to just pull it up again. No, I don't. I'm lying.
I don't hate to pull it up again. I think, >> but like
what is the purpose of saying >> In the background who
own insurance companies and that do kind of weird stuff to try
to pressure people to do stuff like I think it's really weird
and creepy. So, good for you, Wick. Okay. >> What is What
is the purpose of this? If not just randomly naming careers while
talking about this guy and saying he's like doing really disgusting
in the background. Just giving Duby a shout out for his success
as an insurance agent. Wow. He doesn't just do insurance, guys.
He apparently owns a company. Wow. >> Okay. that do kind
of weird stuff to try to pressure people to do weirdo in the
background who own insurance companies and that do kind of weird.
>> It's just Yeah, it's basically just like guys, some
people are not very good at their jobs and they're just employees.
Other people are really great at their jobs like Doobie who owns
a company. Let's go. W Doobie W Dubby's life success and Destiny
celebrating it. That's awesome that Dexi would just include that
to celebrate Dubbie as a human being while totally trying to
sh on him stuff to try to pressure people to do something. I
think it's really weird and creepy. So good. >> Okay. So,
I don't I don't think there's I don't think there's positive
intent there. Do not come off to as a threat to me. Implied or
otherwise. Also, Destiny will just say, "I'm going to dox you."
He has said that to people before. Why would he move to hinting
now? Oh, this argument was just used like two days ago, wasn't
it? Um, this is like the why if Israel wanted to genocide everybody
in Gaza, why wouldn't they just nuke Gaza? They could nuke they
have nukes. Why wouldn't they just nuke Gaza? It's the same argument,
right? What is the uh what is the correlation between weirdo
in the background and owning an insurance company? I don't know.
I don't know. This is not a good argument from Wick, but I'm
getting the feeling that he doesn't argue in Discords a lot.
People have legitimate concern. It sounds like having a heartto-he
heart with Destiny is the best course of action. To me, it was
I know enough about you to shut you up. He was complaining about
the things Doobie was saying and and doing in the background,
right? Weirdo. [__] The the the threat I assume the
threat is because he's complaining about what Doobie is doing
and saying I could with you, too. Anyway, it's really shady how
Destiny said. I I know your full government name and where you
live. Uh, sorry. I feel a kind of way about doctors. No need
to apologize. I know this through disclosure from PV. However,
I think it's reasonable to assume you don't want people knowing
that in here. So, while it's public, I think a reasonable degree
of privacy is assumed in here. At Wick, you guys are hardcore
coping to be honest. Oh, what's Dub Tuby's is going to say something
ridiculous like, of course, Destiny wasn't threatening me. He
was just pointing out how insurance people are. Okay. Haven't
you guys ever had insurance like deny a claim? Insurance people
are scumbags who do shady in the background. That's all Destiny
was saying. See here. Also, community, I need you to stop spelling
docs and doxing wrong. 1x.
Okay. He was clever enough to that it wouldn't surprise me if
he wasn't involved in insurance. Just use it as a tactic. Funny
as hell. If someone tried to dox him, doxed the wrong person,
it blew up in their face. Speak of the devil. That's totally
fair and valid. Oh, this is about It was definitely a stop criticizing
me or I'll dox you warning. Yeah, it was 100% that. Yeah, sure.
Okay, now we actually get to it. Okay, we're about halfway through
these logs. By the way, think what Destiny said about Dubbie
could be interpreted as a threat. Uh, pretty implied. There are
eyes on an awareness of a particular particular individual's
activity within this community and this and other communities.
Not too insane because Dubbie isn't exactly unknown, but it does
reveal that we possibly got some snitches in here. Maybe even
Duby is on radar for his efforts. Be real with yourselves, okay?
It's undeniable. Okay, 9 minutes, son. It doesn't seem like many
people are coping. It seems like most people in this Discord
are like pretty clearly understanding that Destiny is menacing
Doobie right now. It's like wick coping and I don't see another
person coping here, right? You'd have to be painfully naive to
think otherwise. Okay, there bunch of people joking about random.
How is my work relevant to anything? That's a great question.
We were having a great time talking about chorus and and me trying
to see if I could make a show on it. Okay, what what I'm going
to hit all of you.
So, that job is I think this is key. This guy is this guy just
going to totally take Wick's side? I think this is key. I've
personally never heard this about him, but I don't know if that's
something he talks about. Maybe it is. The context of what he
said though was more so that Dubie was doing something shady,
sketchy with his business. So, if Dubie does talk generally about
his work than not a doxing threat, implied or otherwise. However,
the implication Duby is doing something shady, sketchy in regards
to his business is a threat. No, that's not this guy. Is this
guy
Does this guy have a caretaker? How in the world could you possibly
think the shady in the background has to do with Dubbiey's work?
That's crazy. God. To be fair, insurance companies are pretty
predatory. So maybe he was trying to prejudice people against
you that way. Dude, there's no way, right? There's just no way.
There's no possible way that people could be this stupid. Dude,
that's what I I said that jokingly. I said Dubie would come in
there and say that cuz he would sound really saying that like
you would he would be joking and memeing in a way that like would
sort of signal the But damn.
Uh Wix me in my DM DM's begging me to
Maybe we should test this out. Even said he would view. Oh, no,
no, no. On Wick's next stream, we should randomly put out any
personal information anyone in the server has posted or spoke
about publicly. Totally disconnected from the topic of the panel
just because anyway, I did say at the time and I maintain that
if Destiny is going to bring you up, then he should be willing
to talk to you directly.
Wick is like not at all addressing any of this, is he? Uh,
Unfortunate. It's better than what he asks me for an idea. Okay,
I don't care about these people not talking about the topic.
He's a desperate man, says Zona.
People talking about something
While we're here though, I relisted to Dubie segment with Peach.
And I have determined that Dubie is actually like 95% in the
wrong in his segment with Peach. And also Peach's credibility
regarding her other doesn't come into play. I think Zip Zap or
whatever the [__] his dumb name is is at least partially
vindicated. Jeb Tan is the real victim. I don't even know what
that means. Telling the truth is dangerous in Discordia. It's
team sport or get team sports or get get doxed says zona. Dude,
this this is going way too fast somehow. It's like as soon as
there's actually relevant information in the discord scroll like
zooms past it. It's team sport or get doxed. Seems like it. Does
Wick actually tangibly respond to any of these people talking
would be a question. Oh, they scroll back up cuz they went past
it pretty fast. This is what you get for trying to have nice
things, Wick. Also, you're harboring a terrorist or something.
remember 2019.
Okay, I don't care.
>> Dude, there's so many people having like random totally
disconnected conversations.
Jokes aside, can we at least agree it was shady as that he waited
until the end after you said they had should set up a debate
to spout off about him? Oh, there's a doobie clip that we zoom
past. It's not just shady. He was obviously making a threat.
Anyone who says otherwise is pretending to be a for their daddy.
Yeah, basically veiled threat. Easy interpretation. Sure. The
most transparent fabric used for a veil. Someone grew up. Okay.
Dude, this is actually crazy. So many people talk about stuff
that's like not remotely interesting. Yeah, that was lame. Especially
since Wick did so much to keep the peanut gallery down. Wick,
if you don't know, had Destiny come on. He had just a totally
controlled segment for Destiny, right? totally control segment
for Destiny with four randoms coming on to debate him and then
made the donation so that if they wanted to play on stream they
were $40 plus. I think it was very interesting. Only there's
some way to scroll through Wix Discord. I'm not joining Wix's
Discord. Uh it's not to read it. It's okay though. I doubt he'll
actually dox me. If he does, I'll pretend he didn't well enough
that no one will know the difference anyway. Or maybe I'll put
up more breadcrumbs of fake doces and info on myself and eventually
get him or his community to post an entirely doc but play it
up as if it's totally real to justify the unhinged and illegal
behavior that follows. Either way, Wick should probably figure
out his doxing principles. Yeah, probably be a good idea. He's
smart. But all of that makes me feel icky. And I've always been
of the mind that doxing should be illegal except if there was
a news report or some or about something or a crime because there's
a direct public interest component. And yes, I realize there
are levels to doxing. And no, I will not spell doxing with one
X. Okay. Doobie. Doobie doing a bit much. Undoubtedly though,
in what way? Doobie. Doobie. Doing a bit much though. Undoubtedly
though. What? What is the use of this comment?
Like Doobie. I don't No, I don't want anybody to be doxed. Doobie.
Okay, Duby. I would not never want somebody to be doxed. Doobie,
do you understand? I never want that. But like you're kind of,
you know, you're kind of doing a lot right now, Doobie. Okay.
I I'm not saying doxing is okay, but like what did you expect?
What did you What did you expect, Doobie? It's one thing to dox
someone who's actively harming people. It's another to want to
dox someone who said something mean about you and hurt your feifes.
True. That's very true, Dy. Uh that's fake news. I can do way
more. Okay. Like I got nothing against people who are naming
people who abuse kids and do illegal like Lion Maker. As I said,
my exceptions are a news article segment or some kind of some
kind because that's now public record or knowledge of timesensitive
crime, active or imminent, just my own view. How do you feel
in regard to spreading such perpetuating a docu? I just mean
I know Dubbiey's brand of autism. He's been hyperfocused and
locked in on this for a while to the point I do think he's been
making some erroneous arguments or taking leaps in people's state
of mind/intentions.
Example, I hope to be asked for an
This is a a million% fake news, a Google percent fake news. I
talk about things that come up and are relevant to the space
we all around in. Too many people argue about the specific functions
of doxing. The most annoying being it was already public information
which isn't relevant. Okay, keep going. And also things that
interest me politically. Israel Palestine. I don't think I've
made any crazy leaps or arguments either. Honestly, this guy's
not really smart enough for me to care or read through a bunch
of issues. Maybe doces in his server. What an in principled
hack. Your definition of docs is reports them to law enforcement.
Oh, I'm just kidding guys. I'm not against doxing. Aren't you
a frog? We got to be getting through this. Okay, I just watched
it. Most charitable interpretation. Oh, hold on. Let's go back
to this guy saying that. Did I skip it? Oh god,
this is tough. I should have I should have gone and gotten an
Imager album. I'm just going to keep going. I don't think that
comment by Destiny alone warrants him being blocked from the
community. I think it does warrant a heartto-he heart about the
lines he shouldn't cross though between him and Wick. Just take
my take. I agree though in likelihood of it being a veiled threat.
Like odds are it was just can't prove it.
Okay. If he's a hunter, I have no idea. To be pe begged for it.
K. I think it warrants me packaging up everything he's ever done
that causes controversy and sending it to every and any political
campaign left or right across the world to prevent him and his
community's ability from ever participating in politics ever
again.
probably. I I don't know if the threat to Dubie does that, but
I mean, in general, his conduct is probably stuff that people
should be informed of before they partner with him in some way,
right? To be clear though, I'm not pressuring Wick to do anything.
And I don't think Destiny should be deplatformed or lose any
everything or whatever. Wick can do what he wants with his server
and stream. It's his swamp.
Yeah. Ideally, Destiny would just disconnect for a while and
focus on getting his priorities/brain in order so he stops doing
stupid impulsive and hopefully take some responsibility for his
behavior, then works to undo the damage he's done to people.
Then he could come back a new man and show everyone people can
change. Yeah, that would be nice. And in 5 years, they'll make
a movie about it or something. If he did ever actually dox me,
it it would legitimately endanger my wife and child because people
have been trying to dox me for like eight to nine years and I've
been on the receiving end of countless serious death threats
from legitimate violent criminals and satanic cultists.
So if he did that, I'd definitely respond in a not very nice
way.
It's funny. Hold on. What is this dictator 13 guy saying? Can't
trust Jenny on this. He'd lead you. Okay.
Don't care. I don't mean respond online or in court or whatever.
It's just better not to go there. Oh, Dubies. If he doxes me,
I'll do something crazy. Uhoh. That's a little weird, Doobie.
That's a little weird, buddy. I don't think it's that veiled,
to be honest. Well, Duby just made his own veiled thing, so call
it even now. Let's just all get along. This guy is so desperate
to just Guys, stop saying mean things about Destiny. Please stop
talking negatively about Destiny. Please. This prevailing opinion
of like, please just stop talking negatively about Destiny. It's
uh popping up in my own Discord. It's just weird. It's a weird
opinion to have. Guys, could you just stop being mean to this
guy? Could you just stop being What community? What? What? Where
do you think you are? Just stop being mean to this guy. Stop
saying bad things about him. No. No. Okay. So, Doobie talks about
defending his family from Destiny if Destiny attempts to dox
him. Should have handed Pixie like 300k last November/ December
for a confidential settlement and responded to any nukes about
his prior conduct the same way Trudeau responded to the blackface
thing. But instead, this guy doubles down and never
uh would have been cheaper. Could have settled it all the way
with a weepy in person apology to Pixie and a promise to privately
go through sex addiction therapy. That's the typical celebrity
playbook. Pixie wasn't even specifically asking for money. She
just wanted to feel like he understood how bad he harmed her.
Wow. Wow. There's a bunch of people here who share this opinion.
That's crazy. Remember when the drama was fun, dude? Is that
Counterpoint segment good? Counterpoint streamed today and apparently
covered stuff, but I have no idea if it'd be good or funny or
anything. I'm just I'm kind of reading through this a little
silently, right? He shut uh so and he shut down convos with her
despite Erid begging him to just talk to her. He blocked her
if I recall correctly. He said it made him feel uncomfortable
that she was saying she wanted him to be punished. That's what
I recall. Honestly, if he just done that, it would have so much
of the hate he got when this stuff came out. Instead, he just
went on the attack as usual. Damn. People want to believe I was
in a bad place. I'm sorry. People want to believe the I was in
a bad place. I'm sorry. Please help me understand how I can make
you feel okay. And I promise I'll work up to be better at Saab
stories.
H Does this community always devolve into talking about Dude,
this is like so it's so transparent from like
DJers, right? Does this community always devolve into talking
about Destiny? That's literally your That's literally the content
Wick did the night before. It's the last content the streamer
did was a talk with Destiny that generated controversy from that
community. What do you mean? What? Don't shouldn't you feel embarrassed
to come in the night after Destiny was on stream, the night after
he mailed made a veiled threat at a community member where people
had already complained about platforming him in the first place
and you come in, you go, "Guys, it's kind of weird how you guys
are like talking about Destiny right now. I feel like that should
just be a ban. Like that guy is such an incurable
whoever this warbler person is. Warble one, like why would you
have them around? That's like the energy vampire that I have
no patience for anymore, right? It's always a phrase they say
when they have nothing productive to say at all. It seems that
Convos about him died down for a long time until the holding
on to for over a year thing. Unless someone like was in chat
glazing him, but even those combos died quickly. I wonder who
this is. Recently, it's been on uh hold on, please keep going.
Thank you. Recently, it's been the Pisco Blowup, Rose being underage,
and the stuff. There's probably more I'm forgetting. Energy vampires.
Yeah, energy vampires are people who will constantly be proven
like incorrect on the things they say. They'll constantly make
like assertions with no basis to them. And when you point out
that they're making an assertion with no basis, when you point
out that they're saying something, they will go, "Well, I wasn't
talking about that." Well, no, I don't want to talk about No,
I don't know what you're talking No. And then the next day, they'll
bring up the thing you just showed they were wrong on again and
be totally again. They'll have totally reset. It's so exhausting.
Okay. No shame for these people.
Oh, and Dusty openly uh openly doxy people like Jtock and Queenman.
Okay. Trying to failing to. If he just shut up for a while and
stopped doing dumb [__] it would be fine. That is
true. This guy just conceded.
I mean, I don't know enough to have a committed opinion on Destiny.
I tend to defer to the people I know and trust about it until
everything is over, but I understand the analogy and can uh can
see how it would be important to talk about. That will not last.
I'm almost positive that won't last. Oh, look. They got a new
new little thing. New. They're new. Oh, and also him looping
me into a stupid conspiracy theory a few weeks ago. True. Basically
implied he's going to dox me if I don't stop criticizing him.
>> We're got to be close to the end now, guys. We're getting
there. We're getting
>> Yes, it was 95% politics and 5% drama before the pixie
blew up. Is that that might be true? Hold on. What was it? November
January of 2025.
I mean, there was a lot of drama that he'd come on my stream
for and stuff. Just trying to think. He was maybe a little more
focused on politics, but it was like a downturn, a short downturn
if anything. Okay. I'm not sure that that really matters either.
Before people found out about his crimes, he was like 95 pol
95% politics and 5% drama for like 6 months before people found
out about his crimes. Okay, there was a six-month period where
he was really focused on politics. Guys, I'm just looking for
more doobie comments. I'm probably going to get zoom through
this. Okay, we zoom. We zoom. Just zoom in, zoom in, zoom in.
He's here. Too, what's up? How's it going? Welcome to the stream.
>> How are you, buddy? >> Hello. We're doing great.
>> Glad to hear. >> Looking at these uh these logs
of you in the wick cord
having a bunch of people, it seems like arguing with you about
stuff.
Um,
>> so there are like two or three like resident uh Destiny
cultists in the Wick server. Um, they've been there for a long
time, so it's not like it's like a raid or something. >> So,
it's the same people that I'm always arguing with there.
>> But yeah, uh that's
um Yeah, we just having a conversation. I didn't see the uh so
when I was on stream with Peaches a couple days ago, I had no
idea all this like background lore about her like at all. I just
thought it was some like random e girl that like brought on like
he does. So I was very shocked, right, to see those those DMs
from like last year um where she mentions like being sent like
[__] recorded without consent. Um and then today
I was sent another one uh that it lays it out even more clearly.
So um she was [__] talking me in chat. Um someone
tagged me so I hopped in and started [__] talking
back basically. Oh, and just FYI, um my wife and son are sleeping,
but at any any minute they could wake up, uh and they might need
my help or something, so I might need to run off randomly. It's
just FYI. >> Yeah, sure, sure, sure, sure. She the one.
Yeah, I'm not going to go a whole bunch into the like old lore
here, Miss Ellia. But yeah, that is the the case. Um what am
I trying to get to? Yeah, the thing is is Peach also I don't
want to get into too much of the old lore, but she makes a lot
of claims. So, not a reliable narrator in most times. And I say
as somebody who doesn't like Destiny and like uh believes that
Destiny did do the things she alleges, I just don't know that
you can consider her a reliable narrator in this. >> Yeah,
of course. I mean, I wouldn't I totally dismiss it if it didn't
line up with things that came out later, right?
>> seems together. >> How How are you getting called
out by Destiny? cuz I mean I haven't spoken to you in like a
year. Uh year and a half. >> Oh yeah. Hey Becket, how are
you doing? >> It's been Yeah, I'm good buddy. >> Yeah,
it's been a little while. Uh how the [__] you how
how are you getting dragged into this? >> Uh it started
like um
like a month ago maybe. Yeah, I think like like earlier this
month actually. Um, so I was hanging out like after I just cut
ties with Destiny entirely over all the leak stuff and not even
really specifically about the the revenge stuff um or the leak
news or whatever, but really about, you know, that that led me
to look into other behavior of his and other stories that I kind
of dismissed over the years. And I just found like a long pattern
of manipulation, lying, uh, smear tactics, uh, just being a piece
of, right? So I was like, "Okay, well this guy's a piece." Then
I saw how he responded to the leak, right? not taking any uh
personal accountability,
uh just acting like a [__] as usual. So, I was like,
"Okay, I just don't want I just want nothing to do with this
guy, right?" So, I just and that doesn't mean I want to like
take down his platform or whatever. I just don't I'm not interested
in being connected with him in any way, right? Don't want to
help anything. He does want to be on any content with him. Don't
want to be in his stream. Like, nothing. Just I just want nothing
to do with him. So, because Destiny is who I used to listen to
while I was working, right? right? If I wasn't like listening
to an audiobook or something or listening to like a podcast,
um I used to just listen to a stream in the background. And when
I cut like cut ties, I had to listen to other uh so I'd listen
to other streamers. One of them is Pisco, right? And I was listening
to Pisco for for months donating in the stream now now and then.
Um
like uh 10 bucks at a time just whenever I thought I had something
interesting to say or had like a wanted to respond to an argument,
whatever the [__] Um and then he had that bloke with
Destiny. And I was in his server too for months typically arguing
about uh Israel Palestine with his uh regulars or like all like
hardcore Zionist types. And when he had that that blow up with
Pisco somehow because I agreed with Pisco over Destiny and when
Pisco was reacting to it on stream, I was watching the stream
listening to the stream. So I thought Destiny was being a dumbass
and dishonest and just being a piece of so I agreed with Pisco
over Destiny. And this led to people within his community who
I think I think there are regulars within this community on his
admin team and just like regular users who've been there from
the start who are like hardcore DJers who want the bridge
Um and they were and when I started agreeing with Pisco over
Destiny some of them made it very obvious made it very clear
that they thought I was hurting the chances of a bridge being
built right or rebuilt. said they wanted me to shut up and then
they they started like uh and then Destiny said this thing about
like me working with you and with Queen and with Vivian who hates
me by the way. Wait
>> Yeah, Vivian Wolf a couple of my replies talking [__]
as well. So I think >> Vivian despises Vivian's hated me
for trying to dock me for like a long time. >> Yeah. Yeah.
She thinks you're like a
>> Yeah. Um, so he started pushing this stupid thing because
I was agreeing with Pisco for him and I was donating like I usually
do to Pisco stream like 10 bucks as if that's going to change
anybody's >> That's not true. You donate a lot of money
to Pisco stream. >> Well, hold on. I donate 10 $10 at a
time. Okay. The I think the most I've ever donated to a stream
is like 50 bucks in a day, which is like not that's normal, right?
When I'm watching a Wick stream and he's has something interesting
on, I'll donate like $10 $20. when when Wake Wat had on uh Tally,
I I think I donated like a hundred bucks that day just to off
tally. Like it's totally normal. I'm not a poor person. It's
very totally normal for me to do this. So yeah, so like it wasn't
unusual at all for me to be doing that. Um so he framed this
as like me feeding Pisco lies to turn him against destiny, that
kind of thing, which is total nonsense. Like I I was reacting
to what Pisco was already reacting to. So it's just so then when
that happened people within uh Pisco server who are the engineers
started pushing this idea that I was raiding the server with
like anti- Destiny people because other people were coming in
from this massive stream that was happening. They were joining
the Discord server which is totally normal and they were agreeing
with Pisco over Destiny. So they came up with this this conspiracy
theory that I was flooding it that myself and you and Queen were
flooding the server to try to like make sure the bridge was like
remain burned. So, they purge a [__] ton of people.
Um, this guy paid like I think he paid Piscll like $500 the that
night to for to like ban me um and then keep me banned cuz they
didn't actually have like a reason to ban me other than they
just didn't want me there. Um,
so yeah, that's where it started and then it's kind of escalated
from there, I think. Uh, and I've somehow been looped into a
conspiracy with you despite this being the first time we've ever
spoken. Are you are you sure that it's not because you said that
Zip Zip jerked off on the door handle of Pixie's car? >> Oh,
hold on. To be clear now, I think he he jerked off on the windshield.
Like, I'm I'm fully convinced now. >> He jerked off somewhere.
He's a weirdo. >> He jerked off somewhere%. Yeah. Yeah.
>> So, so the the Zip Zip thing was like really silly,
right? So, somebody was uh so he was in chat and Pisco server.
I had no idea who this person was. I don't watch Destiny stream.
I haven't watched the stream for a long time. I had no idea this
guy was on Destiny stream. Um, and people in chat in Pisco server
were saying that this guy like um went to the trial and then
sat behind Pixie to make her uncomfortable, potentially stole
her shoes, all kinds of weird, right? And and Zipo was in chat.
He was in chat >> steal your shoes thing. >> I think
I >> Yeah, I was somebody in Pisco's chat said that uh
that her shoes went missing and that he that he might have taken
them or some [__] So like yeah, I have no idea who
this guy is, right? and he's just being weird in chat about answering
the questions or like responding to people, like being very like
shifty and shady, not responding directly. So, I just asked him
directly like, "Hey, did you actually go to the trail? Did you
sit behind Pixie?" And then he wouldn't respond directly to me.
He's like being very like unnecessarily
mysterious, right? It's a very simple question. I just want to
know, did he go and why did you go? Like, is that I I feel like
it's a normal question to ask. So, because he was being shady
and weird um and started like implying
of people trying to take him down or something. I um well he
started implying that it's part of some group of people just
like trying to like take him down or smear him or whatever the
um I just said. Okay. Well then yeah I believe I believe that
you did it and I think you also came on her car like her windshield
or something or or her door handle. >> Door handle. Door
handle. Yeah. >> Yeah. As a joke it wasn't wasn't a big
deal but apparently this was so devastating to Zip Zip. It's
like a core memory now and he can't stop bringing it up. Like
it's been like over it's been like a month now and every time
they seriously like it's a real allegation like like it's possible
for you to know that or >> Yeah, it's just silly. Anyway,
continue.
>> Yeah, it's it's really it's very strange. Like I don't
know I don't know what's wrong with that kid. Okay. Like I'm
just saying he's a kid cuz he acts like a kid. Something wrong
with him. But yeah, that's all it is. And then uh I guess because
uh oh and the the wick thing is like so yesterday was it yesterday
whenever Destiny was on Wickstream. Okay, it was Thursday actually.
Um there were people within this community who thought it was
a terrible idea. Um like uh I won't name names but regulars within
the community who did not want to have them on. Like I made very
clear Jeban Jeban >> Jeb Jeban was the main one but he's
not the only one. and that and I don't think he'd mind me saying
that, right? Um >> he posted about it publicly, so
>> Oh, okay. Yeah. Yeah. Um and uh but he's not the only
one to be clear. Um and his fear was like that, you know, DG
would overrun the community and you know, Wix Wix community like
his Discord regulars are very small group. So he was worried
that they're going to like overrun the server and whatever, right?
Um I disagree with him and I told him he knows I disagree with
him about that. I don't think that's a concern on Wick server
because the M team is not like proestin or whatever. Um, but
uh I did think that Wick was being uh like hypocritical or he
had like a double standard because he has a no doxing role, but
Destiny's been publicly doxing people, including you, for like
a long time, right? Um, so we're asking him about, okay, like
if if the no doxing thing is serious, then why are you allowing
a doxer here? Like that was just my question, right? Um, and
Wick Wick's response to that was basically like, "Oh, well, you
know, it seems like this doxing rule is like uh I forgot the
wording was, but it was like rather than just like address that
he has a a double standard, he's going to change the doxing rule
in some way, right? To try to like be anti-doxing or ban doxing,
but also allow a doctor on the server." Like it's really stupid,
right? So,
um, so that's it. I just I just criticizing Rick Wick for being
like a unprincipled hypocritical
um or or like having a double standard. I was I never told Wick
not to have him on. Um I I I don't care to like deplatform him
or whatever. The same [__] Connor. Like I I have
no issue with him like being on people's or whatever. It's it's
W's platform. It's Connor's platform. Like it's their business,
right? Um I'm just not going to watch when he's there. That's
it. Like it's not that complicated. >> Yeah. I mean it
sounds totally reasonable. I'm on the same page where it's like
it's I feel like it's impossible to go argue that uh like you
shouldn't platform Destiny just because I don't believe in like
deplatforming in general, right? Like I really strong against
it. So >> I mean I've been on the receiving end of that
like god knows how many times. So I I totally understand like
how silly it can be. >> Oh yeah. So I I don't know. I just
um I find it funny. I don't know why Destiny is like uh like
doing you know fanfiction about so many people at the same time.
I feel like it's got to have some effect on the amount of people
who will believe him, right? When he's like making things up
with no evidence about you, about me, about Queen, about I don't
know, like a bunch of people. I feel like if if he was doing
it one at a time, it would be a lot scarier cuz then he has,
you know, a lot of legitimacy around him or he used to have a
lot of legitimacy around him. Uh now he's just kind of doing
it to anybody who is critical of him. And yeah, I feel like it's
starting to fall apart. >> Well, I mean, he looks just
crazy. Like
true. It's uh it's a real, you know, the the kind of shines come
off it. I I did think it was interesting some of the responses
I've been getting to like tweets about food shops and it's like
all broken English Twitter accounts with like 11 followers talking
about how like isn't a problem. >> Oh, by
I I didn't check that actually. Um I guess I could I guess I
can have a quick look. Um, >> we've started pointing this
pattern out that like a lot of the uh a lot of the totally like
broken English
posters, okay, they they're all followed by Dan. None of them
can type in English. Um, they all come to your replies and they
just say the same like over and over again. Um, it's Listen,
if you're if you're a noticer, you notice, okay? It's hard not
to. >> Uh, so
the first one doesn't isn't followed by Dan, I don't think. and
the other one isn't. I've just picked up two. So, he is he is
innocent of this one. Let's have a look. Uh let's have a look
at this guy with 12 followers.
>> wait, you guys think that they're paying people to
like
>> No,
well, I don't know about paying to me. It seems more like um
I'm guessing there's just like a Discord or something along these
lines where like the tweets get posted and then a bunch of people
show up and >> Oh, okay. >> start replying. I'm guess
I'm guessing it's something like that, but
um but again, like the ones I've got don't have damn following
them. I assume they're just died in the wool food shops fans
who are just really really into food shops and her content, you
know, that massive community that's existed for years. Oh, dude.
>> Oh, to be So, somebody mentioned this in chat um a bit
ago about the uh comment I made about your voice on Connor's
stream. Um, so to be clear, I want to publicly apologize to Mr.
J. >> It's really, you understand? When I said that to
you in DMs, it was like a total It was >> Hold on. Can
I Can I Can I say naughty words on this like on this stream?
I don't know whether rolls on kick. >> Uh, it depends.
You I It depends on what it is. >> Just the word you sent
me in DMs. >> No, don't say that. Just slur. >> Okay,
whatever. Um, >> you train ourselves out. >> I thought
I thought this I thought this was America. It's fine. Um, so
yeah. So, I was I was talking about uh Wolf Gand. Sorry, Wolf
Gand. I I feel that way about your voice. I'm sorry. Which is
fine. People say that I sound trans or gay or fat or um or Indian
all the time. Like I it's some some people just don't like voices.
It's fine. >> Okay. All right. Well, uh thank you. >> That
was not too complicated. >> Clarifying the misinformation.
>> No problem. So, um >> I don't really say apparently
>> Destiny doubled down on the uh the allegation or sorry,
he doubled down on like uh he went on the food shops stream after
after Wick I guess the next day and did like resay that oh yeah,
this guy totally does sell insurance. That's what he does or
something. Like it's like he's going to keep going. I don't >> Yeah,
it's fine. >> That's what it is. >> Like on I I shouldn't
say too much, but it's it's fine. Um, so, um,
yeah, I I just think that he's like desperate. It just makes
him look desperate, right? Like I don't criticize him any more
publicly than like any of the other people criticizing him do.
And it's all for that's available publicly. Like it's not, you
know, it's not like I have uh secret intel that I'm bashing him
with. Or I'm not going to Pisco's DMs or Wick's DMs or Conor's
DMs and trying to get them to deplatform him. I mean, I'm sure
if you were to ask Bisco, Connor, and Wick directly, they would
tell you that I've never done that, right? And I've never pressured
them not to have him on at all. Um, >> I don't pressure
Connor not to have him on. I just pressure Connor to be like
cuz I I just tell Connor about the times he said that he would
have to like distance himself from a doctor. He thought it was
like some of the most cowardly disgusting behaviors that he can
think of online. And I just like we'll send him something new
that's happened. I'm like just hoping your conscience kicks in
at some point. He's the only person I'll be annoy annoying with
because he's the only person who's like moralized the issues
pretty hard. >> Yeah. I So I've known Colin for
uh god I don't even know how long. Maybe like seven years or
some [__] right? A long time. And um like he was
one of the first people I met when I started going to stream
to like troll and lar fascist.
Uh and yeah, I so I do have a soft spot for Connor. So maybe
I'm I'm just like more patient with him than I should be. But
I think his justification is sort of like is basically aerodites
which is like uh oh and Wix apparently now I saw a clip of Wix
saying that you know if that if I were Destiny's friend he wouldn't
have done this kind of thing. Um like Connor my understanding
of his like position is
um he feels like he needs to be there to pull Destiny away from
the uh sin or whatever the which I can understand. You know I've
had friends who were doing terrible that I felt obligated to
stick around and try to help and try to get to change their behavior.
Um, but I mean I think in a lot of those cases it's like the
person needs to hit rock bottom. The only way for them to do
that is for you to stop enabling them or making excuses for >> Wait,
I'm sorry. So Wick's argument is that if Destiny and him were
friends that none of this would have happened. >> Am I
getting said something along those lines? Yeah, you said something
along those lines. >> This is the most parasocial insane
>> Bro, what the dude? How do you like how do you as a
content creator say this stuff where it can be played back to
you and you not see how it sounds? I don't I don't understand
the I think Wick's got a library. So >> I think I think
W was saying that he uh he wouldn't have done it because he'd
have like a better example, right? or better uh like in Wick
like to to to deed and like not do that kind of stuff which is
I think the probably the dumbest [__] I've ever heard
especially in the context of Wick like provably having uh I don't
want to say he has no principles but he at least doesn't have
some of the principles he says he has right so like I don't know
it's just kind of silly but I mean I've argued with Wick god
knows how many times over the years disagreed with him passionate
about all kinds of I it doesn't mean that I want to like you
know I'm going to like pressure him not to to do [__]
with his platform or who, you know, I'm going to like disconnect
from him or whatever. So long as he doesn't do anything that
I think is like morally like objectionable. Uh, and right now
I I just have Wick in the category of like small streamer. He's
trying to become a big streamer. This guy is good for well he
thinks this guy's good for you know the growth of his platform
so he wants to uh, you know, take advantage of that which I can
understand. >> Yeah. Yeah, that's fair. Uh, Benny, what's
up? How's it going?
Welcome to the conversation.
>> Hi. I don't mean to interrupt. I only had one thing
to ask. I had a question for Doobie.
>> You can ask me anything you want. >> Doobie is
on a uh he's on a long list
>> Oh, are you going to sign the Mr. Girl apology form,
Duby?
>> He's on a long list of the people who have to sign the
form. >> I I've actually Hold on. So, I've actually considered
this uh I was talking I was I think I spoke to Kilo about this
in DMs like like almost a year ago. I've considered this deeply,
right? Um,
and I think that with the information I had at the time, I I
don't regret what I did. I think that it was the right thing
to do with the information I had at the time. Obviously, in hindsight,
with more information, I would have made a different decision,
but with what I had at the time, I think it was the right thing
to do. >> Okay. Now,
correct me if I'm wrong, but you lied to Mr. girl and said that
you had information about Destiny being a piece of and then he
said, "Okay, tell me the information." And then you used that
as
evidence that Mr. Girl is a bad person. Even now that it literally
it didn't make any sense back then, but I understand how the
cult lapped it up. But even now, it still doesn't even make any
sense how that could even be a bad thing that he did. >> No,
that's not true. Or at least that's not how the conversation
went. Um >> Yeah. How the conversation went. I don't have
access to it. I think there are like screenshots that are out
there, I'm sure, uh on Destiny Stream or whatever of like the
full conversation.
Um but I don't I don't have access to those DMs anymore. But
off the top of my head, what I remember is him approaching me
randomly asking me for um
like uh if I had a way to get in touch with um I think Denims,
if I remember correctly. I think Bad Bunny maybe. And at the
time I did have a way to get in touch with them. um sort of right
like kind of like second hand through my mods. Um
and he brought up this like uh this accusation of like I forgot
the word was. Um, so whatever I'm saying just off the top of
my head, so if you look up the wording, it's probably going to
be different, but my understanding is he was like priority, pressuring
women or whatever on his stream and uh it seemed like he was
baiting me to ask him about it and I didn't ask him about it
initially and then he kept I felt like he was kind of like kept
pushing it, trying to get me to ask about it. So I asked about
it and then that's when he kind of laid out what he was doing
and because I like I said I listened to Destiny's dream um while
I was working back then. Um I'd heard uh Max say countless times,
you can trust me. If there's any ever any problem, I'll come
to you first. You know, I'd never do anything behind your back,
etc., etc., right? And he like was begging uh Destiny to like
open up to him, be a friend to him, trust him, etc. So for him
to like for him to after doing all that publicly over and over
again
um for him to like not just go to Destiny first that really didn't
sit sit well with me. So I just couldn't I didn't feel right
about helping him and I felt like I should tell Destiny like
hey this guy who's been begging you to trust him for months now
is actually backstabbing you.
>> Okay, I understand that rationale. >> Yeah. So,
like I said, at the time with what I had, um, it did if it was
right I think it was the right thing to do from my perspective.
Now, looking back, I I obviously would do something different
if I had access to more information. >> But, I mean, isn't
that sort of Mr. Girl's fault for coming out with not enough
information? 50% of the doc is just that happened to Lav. >> I
think there's
information gathering, right? November 11th, 2022, doc gets released
somewhere around March 2023. >> Uh, I mean, wait, which
stuff are we talking about here? like this.
>> Reacting to messages from from uh Mr. Girl. I'm assuming
November 11th, 2022. This is like way before the doc is >> Yeah.
So that was um so that I think he messaged me after Destiny did
the Nuke stream. And Destiny did the Nuke stream after I sent
him the messages um between myself and Max where I kind of like
let him on a little bit to try to get him to tell me what he
was doing in more detail. And then I was just sending all that
to Destiny. >> I'll just read from top to bottom. Mr. Girl.
Hey man, I didn't realize I never wrote back to this, but I have
to ask you for something. Do you know Denims or a Kira chat/bad
bunny? Debbie says, "Sort of. I've interacted with both. Denims
was more recently and Kira chats like three years ago. So, you're
trying to get in touch? I'm not sure how much I can help you.
I don't know this." Oh, this is chat from Destiny's stream. I
see. Mr. Girl says, "They both think I'm aligned with Destiny
and are hesitant to talk to me. I'm trying to get in touch with
them to talk about a disturbing pattern of abuse of female streamers
in DG Off the Record." Gibby responds. Hm. Some of my mods might
be closer to them than I them than I am. I can put out feelers
and see if either would be willing to come on for an AMA. That'll
open up a path of communication I can use to push them your way.
Max says, "Thank you. I don't know how to feel about Destiny
personally, but I am hearing some disturbing." DB responds, "I
think he's entertaining, but any interaction I've had with him
I've had with him over the years has just been networking for
debates or server outreach. I don't know him personally beyond
that." Max responds, "Okay." >> Yeah, there there are more
DMs after that. Um, >> I just don't have access to right
now,
>> Yeah, getting more specific about
>> Yeah, actually something I want to take credit for this
on stream now, actually. So, there was that uh that uh thing
going around about being the Weinstein of Twitch. Uh I want I
want to say I came up with that. Okay, that was my line with
Max and it's been regurgitated all No, I gave it to M. I said
that to Max and I think he said it to L. So, I'm taking credit
for it. Yeah. You know, there was there's way more uh between
that last thing you read and and the ones you're looking at right
now. >> Yeah. Yeah. Um I mean, I also just know that it
was uh I don't know, man. People make decisions the best they
can with the information they have. It's kind of rough though,
just uh knowing what you know now. >> Yeah. Yeah. It sucks.
I mean, I feel like I um definitely uh Well, maybe not. Well,
I'm just going to say I think I feel like I definitely like contributed
to the behavior continuing in some way. Um because I just didn't
have enough information at the time. >> Yeah. What is this?
>> So, I do feel bad about it and that's why I've like
seriously considered apologizing or reaching out to Max or something.
But I just feel like if I were to do that, it would be for me,
not for him, you know, cuz I don't think he'd ever trust me again.
I think it's reasonable for him not to trust me again. And I
actually don't feel like I did anything wrong at the time. So,
if I were to apologize to Max, it would be to help myself and
not really to me
All right, you're off the hook. You're off the hook. There there
are more people that need to fill out this form.
But uh >> Benny's really really good content a lot of the
time and then once in a while he used to come on and ask somebody
to fill out the form. So we accept the good with the bad, you
know. >> That's the bad. >> Yeah, it's kind of weird
sometimes,
>> but it's it's understandable. >> I mean, when
I when I say when I say fill out the form, I'm not being serious.
I'm just I'm just asking about like um their mind frame when
they did something and how they feel about it in hindsight really
>> and it's kind of topical >> little topical sure
they're an actual
>> sorry continue Benny >> obviously I'm framing
it around Mr. Girl but like I mean this has to do with the Destiny
thing but but yeah that's it that's all that's all I uh that's
all I had to ask. >> Okay, fair enough. >> Gregor
Sam says Mr. Mr. Girl is literally minimizing the Rose drama
on his stream right now. [__] Mr. Girl. I think he's
probably just saying that he doesn't think Desty's, which I think
most people agree with if you go by the dictionary definition.
Probably not a Oh, well, Benny's gone. Benny was going to start
sweeping. He wasn't going to be able to control it. >> I'm
trying to I was trying to be nice. I listen I hate Mr. Girl.
That's I don't think that's a secret to anybody.
>> Interesting.
What do you hate exactly? Um, so I disliked Mr. Girl when Stardust
and him were still friendly.
And like there's something about Max. I think the thing I've
said most is there's something about Max that's I think is intensely
up. I think the Max is the sort of person that would rather think
you think that he's a than what's actually wrong with him. I
think I think he's u a massively manipulative control freak.
And when the Destiny drama happened, my one of my big things
was like, dude, the Destiny drama between Mr. Girl and Destiny
happened, and people seem to forget this because Mr. Girl was
being bullied by Destiny's subreddit, and I refuse to respect
anyone who can be bullied by Reddit. It is the gayest thing possible.
And he like, "Dude, you shouldn't pay any attit
uh make sure they're a bit nicer to me." That's what caused the
blow up. And then it got turned into this whole kind of well
Destiny's a manipulative abuser and that's why no one took it
seriously. And then he puts out like dude unironically
I think Smith
put out a better Google death you do than Mr.
>> Apologize to
it's totally gay to complain to a Reddit. I agree with you. Do
you think he was wrong in the things he said about the Reddit?
>> Uh I think it's irrelevant. I don't know whether it's
right or wrong. I think it's just irrelevant. I mean, I don't
know if he's wrong about it in the sense that yes, Destiny's
Reddit is like or was like pretty aggressive, but again, why
do you care? That's the true of like most communities. I don't
really I don't think that's unique to Destiny. And Max was putting
himself in a position of like, oh, we're friends and therefore
you should protect me. which I think is a pretty gay position
with any content creator if you're going to them and going, "Oh,
can you protect me from your community?" If I sat here and was
like, "Hey, I've just seen that somebody in the chat said Becket
is an Fler," which is an objectively true fat fact, but can you
ban them? Like, it's just I I don't know what you meant to do
with that. >> Let's say we had an argument. I had the way
bigger platform and I'd like lost that argument and people in
my subreddit or in my chat were saying I lost the argument. If
I only ban the people who are aggressive towards me and let all
of the most insane people towards you stay, wouldn't that make
you feel like a little weird? Especially if we consider >> No,
it's your community. You can do whatever the [__]
you want with that. This this whole kind of I wish people's Yeah,
I just I don't hold the standard. >> I I think and also
I think that's >> you cannot hold the standard, but I think
it's like just really obvious that that's weird. >> Okay,
but my statement here is like I think Mr. G and I think anybody
who acts this way about communities that they're like interacting
with in the chats uh that has a similar tech is a [__]
So >> Yeah. But I don't think Mr. Girl would argue he's
not a I think he would say, "Yeah, I'm sensitive. Over sensitive
maybe." Yeah,
>> But yeah, I mean the the the doc itself, if Mr. Girl
had managed to get more information, I think like the Anavoir
stuff on re-examination
is obviously really bad, but I think that got swept pretty hard.
>> So yeah, you could probably make arguments around that,
but I don't know if that's uniquely Max, right? Was was Max the
only voice saying that Anavir had been over over the years? Can't
believe that's true. >> I don't think there was a lot of
people on Anavore's side. I don't I don't think so. Unless I
missed it. >> Pretty much. Yeah.
Seal of approval. I [__] love it. It's so perfect.
Also, Mr. Girl started a war with Destiny subreddit that then
got upset he was losing. That was pathetic. He could write what
he wants on his own subreddit. Um, yeah, he got shown why people
like basically shape narratives on their own subreddits, right?
Why they ban people who are super like overcritical of them and
he tried to ban nobody and then his subreddit was just like crazy
for a while. Kind of a bad decision when you go to war with a
way bigger subreddit that is like known for like kind of jointly
participating in other places and then you say you're not going
to ban anyone, but then they just all go jointly participate
in your subreddit and your subreddit just becomes anti-U.
Like you kind of you kind of played yourself there a little bit,
right? You literally started a war with a group that's totally
fine with doing that and said you weren't going to moderate it.
You were going to just let the ideas stand on their own. Turns
out that group was cultlike and they the ideas did not stand
on their own. >> I mean this is like for me people can
be like that's a gay take or whatever back at like that's how
I run my people don't get banned from my chat. People are uh
mean to people I have on. Um and in the same way if I'm like
I don't know if I'm on Chuds and Chud's audience is super mean
to me cuz loads of people in Chud's audience just like me. That's
fine. I've got I've got no complaints. So yeah, I think that's
I think that's probably a more mentally healthy way to deal with
things because you know if you're just
>> well you don't. >> Yeah, I would just argue in
Chuds that he's not going to he's not going to moderate people
being mean to him
>> right? Like people can be mean to Chud and I I don't
think he's like moderating those people out just cuz they're
making jokes at his expense or something, >> right? I just
think >> he moderate out people who annoy him though. Yes.
and he will moderate based on what people have said. Like if
if someone gives a take if he's talking about something and someone
deeply disagrees with his take or like he thinks they're making
a argument, he'll theatrically ban them. So it's not like he
doesn't moderate against himself like either. Like people can
him, but that comes down to what you care about. I don't know
if that's a onetoone. If Shan didn't ban anyone at all, then
I'd see the argument, but he does. and people get banned from
spicy chat and from like
other other groupings that >> I thought it was really funny
that um he was accusing me of being like looked in with Queenman
or whatever cuz actually like the last time I spoke to Queenman
um was a massive argument with him and Chud and DK
um about like uh this Elder Alderzi that happened like two years
ago and I got banned from spicy chat back and I haven't spoke
to them since. Right. don't like >> uh I heard you fought
hard on the Elder Drazzy thing. Um I did. >> What part
of what part of that was like doxing when he used his real name
on his TikTok that was connected to the Elder Drazzy persona?
>> Yeah. So obviously it was a stupid thing to do. So my
issue was more that um after they were aware um that uh he did
not want it public and he was being harassed whatever the there
were a lot of people in the server that continued to post it.
Um continued like I think people were like even posting pictures
of his mom. not his mom, his uh wife or whatever the [__]
Uh they were posting his name. Um just a ton of people, right?
So that's that's what I was off about, right? That it seemed
like they were had like um I be like infantilizing
the elders as like a harmless dude. Okay. Harmless guy kind of
silly sometimes. So it circling the wagons around and poking
fun at him with public private information. They know he doesn't
want post like is
>> breaking up pretty hard here. Just so you know I or
maybe you're fine now. Sorry about that. >> I do think
that's possible that it's like wrong. I I would say it's weird
to me that like Drazzy apparently had no problem with it and
went back and like played Street Fighter with those people like
months later. >> Yeah, I think um yesterday or the day
before he said that no he's he's okay with his name being out
there if I remember correctly.
>> Um but at the time he was really upset it like like
really upset about it. like I was in a group down with him and
he was not happy about it. So,
um yeah, I just felt like it was up for them to bully this dude
um and repeatedly post this when they knew he didn't he wasn't
okay with it. Like that's all that was. >> I see. Yeah.
Yeah, makes sense. Okay, fair enough. Um
okay, not totally sure what I I do want to ask. Okay, did that
lost guy ever post anything? He said he's gonna post. He said
he had the proof. I actually sent it. Uh oh, I sent it to but
no, he didn't post anything. Um I think that the only thing I
ever posted though was like a flag for some reason. Uh but no
and actually spoke to him. Well, Lacto was speaking to him in
Wick server cuz we all hang out in Wick server pretty often,
right? Like while we're working, whatever. Um so the next day,
Lacto was speaking to him in there. And he agreed that there
was nothing, right? And and it kind of shifted from the claim
he was making that evidence to
Quimman and uh J Stalk or whatever. I think he calls it like
stalker. Um where uh you know like uh formed a community or have
a community that uh enables doxing or some [__] like
that which and in the context of Destiny publicly doxing people
for months is ridiculous, right? And even still, there's no evidence
that I've find and he was able to find of you or anything like
that. >> So, he just he went from one claim that he has
no evidence for to another claim he has no evidence for. It's
going to take him like weeks or months to figure out that he's
on this one, too. >> Uh yeah. Um we move
uh DM with Willie Mac. >> Oh, sorry. You're you're breaking
up really badly now. Do you have like connection issues or is
it maybe let me try one thing and then we'll see if this changes
anything. Give me a sec. I'm going to go like Yeah, that's going
to reconnect us. Sometimes it's I sometimes auto set the Discord
node. >> Yeah, that's better. I think I think that's better.
Sorry. So I think I I lost where you're going, but you you're
responding to the loss in question cuz he was on the
right and he had no evidence and I I think he tried to like actually
he actually tried to talk to you about like I'll prove I'll prove
I'm going to give way more evidence than Duby gave for anything
he said. Right. And then >> yeah, I posted a ton of vlogs
of Destiny
publicly doxing people, encouraging people to dox people and
he didn't post anything in there. So in Wick server the next
day um we talked about that. He agreed. There's no evidence he
knew of, but it was he shaved he shifted to well they they formed
a community that enables oxing or some [__] like
that. No evidence for that. And then we went max DM right where
he has he still whatever >> you're you're breaking up.
>> Yeah, I know. I'm breaking up again. God damn it. Hello.
Can you hear me? Say it is so [__] up. So he went
to the the Willie Mackiums and we were reading the Willie Miams
where he's it's very I mean he says repeatedly that he still
has the videos and he's he justifies having the videos gives
a stupid hypothetical for keeping the videos and even reading
them to him with him he could not accept that he that they he
couldn't accept that they said what they said he said there must
be some other reason cuz Destiny's not that stupid. There must
be some other thing that this means because Destiny's not that
stupid. It's like hardcore like cultist [__] Like
it's I don't know. I don't know how how to explain. There's there's
such trust that he's so he's so smart. He would never do something
like this even if it's right there in the [__] games
in front of him. It's so [__] weird. >> Uh
really had a hard time believing that Destiny would dox this
girl um not knowing that she was 18 as well. Like that you would
go and help Kiwi Farms dox this person who was a minor when you
were them. Like uh people just have a very hard time breaking
out of that mindset. Like unfortunately, they just have to admit
that Destiny like kind of is have in like a total spiral where
he's making incredibly decisions and
blowing his career up. Seems seems to be the case.
Yeah. What if Rose is a twin? The best hypothetical. >> Yeah.
I I think my internet connections uh revoling against me right
now. Maybe maybe they did find me and they're detoxing me or
something. Should be really funny, actually. Um but but uh yeah,
I I don't know. The only way that I can explain it is it's it
is behavior like I don't know. I I always have this meme it seem
like when reality is in front of denying it. It's just >> Yeah.
Um that that sucks cuz uh that guy used to watch my stream a
lot and obviously he uh he donates a lot to stuff and he asked
me about it. He asked me about it like a couple months ago and
I was like yeah I totally like join Wick server and go through
this stuff with you guys if you want to see like some of the
evidence around things or whatever. and he never followed up
on any of that. And then like maybe two or three months later,
I just saw him like donating to Wick saying like all of this
about everything about Destiny is a lie, like giving like $50
or something. And I was just like, "Oh, well, he seemed kind
of reasonable before. It's kind of weird how he just went off
a deep end." And then Yeah. So I I don't know. It's bizarre.
Bizarre seeing him on a panel and then being like, I have proof
of this and then providing no proof. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Very strange. But um is there anything else
you had for me and Mr. Any other questions you had? Anything
else I can help out with? >> Um I don't think so. I think
I'm gonna go watch possibly this like food shop segment. Got
a whole Connor thing going for it. So we'll have to go check
that out and see how that goes. Becky, do you have any questions
for Dubbie? You curious about anything? >> No, I think
that's filled in quite a lot. I was really surprised to even
hear your name mentioned, frankly. Like it's it's kind of wild.
But yeah, no, that does fill in a lot of kind of bizarre gaps.
I Yeah, basically I if Destiny's at this point, the paranoia
is really set in, right?
You know, I >> I don't I don't believe he believes that
I'm part of any conspiracy or anything like this or I'm doing
anything in the background, quote unquote. Like, I don't think
he actually believes that. I think he's just trying to spread
the narrative that I am because he gives his soldiers like Lost
and his cult members um something they can cling to to avoid
reality. like Duby must be lying because he's a creepy uh insurance
guy who would hate sesame as part of this conspiracy. Like that's
like it's some some stupid [__] like that cuz I know
that he doesn't believe that this nonsense he's >> Man,
it's crazy just how uh Trump like it is, right? That it's like
literally anybody criticizing becomes a part of a conspiracy
like immediately with no evidence. And it's like the exact thing
that Trump does to people like he will just start maligning them
with like no evidence. He'll just say [__] about
them. Um, I don't know. I find it very interesting that he like
has had this obsession with how evil Trump is for going on like
nine years now and he's like become the thing he hates. Very
very bizarre. >> Yeah. Even the uh I noticed that um that
Zip Zip guy was using the same creepy and weird, right? Is it
they're doing the uh the JD Vance thing, right? Say say JD Vance
is weird, right? And and that that'll take him down for sure.
Like it's weird. I I don't It's just childish. Like I don't know.
It's um it just comes off as like desperate to me. So I don't
know. Uh hopefully he figures out his [__] pretty
soon. I'll talk to you guys later. Let me know if you need anything
else. >> Yeah. All right. Thanks for coming on, Dies. Talk
to you later. Bye. >> See you.
>> I shall also leave you to to watch food shops and uh
enjoy whatever unhinged
that is. I need to I need to go through and watch that Destiny
stuff myself. >> Oh, sorry. I didn't know I could actually
click right back into the room. Sorry about that. Uh I have can
I say one more thing? Is that okay? >> Uh yeah go for it.
>> So I noticed two things in chat. Um I don't use look
at cake very often unfortunately. Um but I noticed two things.
So one is Ginger Roth is in chat. I love Ginger. Hi Ginger. Good
to see you again. Two um somebody asked if I was trolling when
uh I was disagreeing with Chad about Dr. K. Yeah, I was. So,
a lot of what I used to do on Twitch uh at the start is
um just LAR is whatever the most uh controversial position was.
Um typically is like a fascist or a crazy person, whatever, right?
Uh Wick wasn't Wick knew about this. Prime knew about this. Ch
knew about this. Destiny knew about this. Uh Fanatic like they
would just say, "Hey, I need I need somebody to argue this. Can
you do it?" And I would do it. Like that was it. And it was just
to funnel people to my server. Like it's that's all it was. So
yeah. >> Wow. Do you uh do you make money from your politics
server? So like a actual >> It's just uh No, we've um people
have pushed us to like call like colonize uh monetize it for
a long time. Uh but I don't feel right about it and I don't need
the money. So it's just a hobby. Um yeah, just
best and biggest politics around Discord by the way. But yeah,
it's just it's just a hobby. I just like having people to argue
with so is what it is. All right, cool. >> Hey, talk to
you later. Thank you. Bye. >> Nice. Cool. Right, I'll peace
out as